[Music]  you'll feel like you're waiting for  something that happened it pains me to  see you embarrass your father but you  don't know what it is you're in or  you're out  that thing that could it's your life  special  you're in  or you're out  durian  oh you're not how can I tell you if I'm  in or I'm out without you telling you  the first thing about what I might be in  around this would be something dangerous  and very exciting this library is home  to the most valuable book in the United  States twelve million dollars you really  need to see how easy this is gonna be oh  you know this from all your previous ice  [Music]  can I just say how dumb this entire  thing is how do you know no one's gonna  get hurt I don't want you waking up  years from now  wondering why could it happen and who  you could have been are you sure you're  okay  oh my life this isn't some game  [Music]  keep please in a touch come on oh thanks  [Music]  let's do this  [Music]  you